hey what's up guys my name is the China
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we extended our 2d renderer
and added texture support check out that
video if you haven't already and we've
been on this little kind of series here
where we've just been working at this
render a 2d that we have which is just a
2d renderer which we're eventually going
to make the standard kind of all
encompassing 2d renderer and hazel and I
kind of like this
I guess this section of the game I
deserves because every week I'm gonna
just add more and more building blocks
to that renderer and today we're going
to be taking a look at a little bit of
an optimization but also just kind of
like a fun little trick that we can do
to simplify our 2d renderer because
right now we've got kind of two sections
to this there's well there's this draw
quad function which does everything in
the tree renderer so far but it either
draws a flat color quad so if we want
like a red or a blue square or something
like that or any kind of rectangle we
use that function but then there's also
the draw quad that actually takes in a
texture that's how we're drawing kind of
the checkerboard background so we that
we had at the end of last video now
that's great and it's you know it's
obviously required for us to basically
have a flat color drop one function and
then a textured one as well because it's
pretty often in a tree renderer that you
would of course want to draw like a kind
of quad or something that that is a
particular color but then also textures
are very common and you know we need
both of those functions I don't think I
need to explain that to you guys but the
problem is that they require a complete
kind of state switch so in other words
what has to happen is we need to
basically we have to write two different
shaders and then when it comes time to
render this what actually happens in the
render 2d function is because we're
doing immediate mode Ren right now
anyway basically you know we're
immediately kind of binding the shader
and then doing the draw call and there
were two different shaders and you know
swishing shaders is like a huge thing
and in like I mean in OpenGL it's
probably not the biggest kind of thing
but just in graphics programming in
general if you want to switch your
shader like that could potentially be a
massive operation and that's definitely
something that we want to avoid now of
course there are ways to mitigate that I
mean we could for example to
in every club that we want to draw into
some kind of like draw lists and kind of
like command buffer essentially and then
that way we could you know if you kind
of do drop work with color so draw color
draw texture drop color draw texture or
something like that right interleaved
which would be inefficient if you put
the every time you do that if you
actually just kind of put them into that
relevant draw command buffer and then
what happens is at the end when you have
all that information you know that you
want to draw like fifty quads with
colors and fifty quads with textures you
basically do them in two groups
so you bind your shadow you do all the
quads you bind to a texture shader and
then you do all the textured quads which
is fine like that would be that would be
a huge performance benefit right there
immediately by not having to continually
switch your entire graphics State
however there's something that we can do
better and that is we can just have one
shader we don't need two shaders to draw
a texture or color we can actually just
use one shader and that requires a
little bit of setup and we'll talk about
that today will basically make it work
today but the plan is let's just get rid
of having these two different shaders
let's just do everything in the one
chair but first want to give a huge
thank you to all the patrons that made
this series possible patron uncle 4/2
sure knows the best way to support this
series apart from getting access to like
the 3d kind of rendering version of
hazel with like you know a full viewer
and everything like that which I've
talked about in previous episodes as
well as kind of standalone videos you'll
also get access to exclusive videos and
I'm doing exclusive videos about once a
week now so I just released want a
couple days ago which was basically
introducing Vulcan and - hazel because
I've been working on that in the last
few days so if you guys are interested
in stuff like that and just want to kind
of keep up with what I'm doing because
obviously this game engine series is
very kind of public-facing that's just
like a tutorial series where we go
through episode by episode where as what
I'm doing behind the scenes in what I'm
doing I guess in my kind of personal
life so to speak not personal life
personal life that is in like the
programming that I'm doing outside of
what you see in these tutorial series if
you're interested in stuff like that
then definitely check out patreon don't
come close to the channel cause you'll
get access to all of those exclusive
videos you'll get access to just
everything that's in the backlog
immediately which i think is pretty cool
you can also
Instagram if you want I've basically
been trying to be more active there
lately and I'm going to be posting
videos on just what I'm doing day to day
kind of on Instagram stories and stuff
so that's a thing if you're into that
then check out the links in the
description alright sir - shaders let's
collapse that into one chatter let's
talk about first of all how we can even
make that happen so just looking over
the architecture here it's fairly basic
like if we look at the actual draw
commands that we're issuing here we have
our begin scene and then we have two
quads that are drawn one is red one is
blue and then we have a checkerboard
texture now this kind of check of what
texture is very big there's a scale it's
a lot bigger than anything else is kind
of acting as a background but ultimately
what happens is when we draw a quad with
a color so this last parameter being a
color instead of a texture what it
basically does is bind our flat color
shader set that float for uniform which
is the actual color and then set up a
transform which is which has to be done
for both cases anyway and then we just
kind of find the vertex try and do the
draw if we look at the texture version
what that does is it just binds the
texture so really the only thing ah
sorry binds the texture shader says the
transform mm binds the texture and in
fact I might just move the texture to
being before the transforms the
transform kind of do last no particular
reason for that just organization
purposes because you can see that this
more closely matches what we have over
here okay cool it's the only way these
are the two kind of important functions
in here we're doing the shader binding
and the color uniform right but here
we're doing instead of the black color
shadow we're binding the texture shader
and then we're doing the texture binding
so those are the two big differences and
of course what that means is that we do
have two shaders now last time I showed
you guys a pretty cool little thing that
we could do if I go to my share to here
we're going to assets shaders and then
texture shadow no text without geocell
so what this was was the actual texture
that we wrote and then what I did was
instead of basically I did two things to
kind of modify your typical texture
shader here first of all I multiplied
the Tetra corners by 10 which gave us
that tiling effect because that extra
sampling mode was set to repeat and then
this is me multiplying our texture the
result of our texture sample right which
is basically the color of that pixel of
the texture that we're gonna render
we're multiplying that color by another
color right in this case you can see
that while we're keeping the red and the
alpha channels the same but then we're
kind of lowering the green and blue
channels to about 80% wall to exactly 80
percent of their value right so we're
basically tinting it red because we're
leaving red alone but then changing blue
and green now that's fine and that's
going to be the basis of how we're going
to be able to combine basically both of
these shaders into one right in the case
of us having a color a color shader so
we don't want any kind of texture
rendering at all we basically need to
bind the texture here that is gonna be
pure white if we leave this unbound
it's kind of probably will it's I think
it's technically undefined in most
drivers that I've seen it's just gonna
return black right and black of course
having a value of zero means that if we
won't supply it with a color that's also
gonna give us zero which is useless it's
just gonna give us black whereas we want
to basically have a texture that we can
sample from that just returns one being
like pure white right and then of course
if we kind of multiply one by anything
while this one kind of gets factored out
of the equation it's almost like we have
a little branch that just says ignore
that you know we're just gonna use the
color and then of course in the reverse
case so when we want to sample from the
texture because we bound the texture and
we don't want to use the color at all
all right then you basically can just
set this color to one and then if you
set that color to one then it it gets
kind of it's irrelevant to the equation
so that's that's the idea now of course
we could take a more simple approach
here by basically just having a uniform
ball or something like that that just
basically says you know am i using
texture bound or something like
am i using a texture and then if we do
that we could just have like a little
branch that says if the textures bound
sample from the texture if it's not then
use the color that's not really ideal or
efficient at all it's much better to
basically just have a default texture
bound that is just gonna be basically a
one by one texture right really tiny
texture that just has the value one
there as our default texture and then
sample like this instead of doing any
kind of branch swishing okay so that's
the plan for today it should be pretty
simple to implement let's just dive in
and take a look at how we can do that so
the first step to this is that texture
right if we just kind of take this away
right and actually the first thing I
might do is modify the shader so let's
get rid of this flat color shader this
texture shader that we have here I'll
still call it texture shader even though
it's gonna be more than that so we'll
get rid of that color shade up and then
this texture shader that we have here
let me just open this now also having
the flat color one because we need to
steal some things from that so this flat
color shader has this uniform that I
want which is the you color uniform so
if we go back to our shed what I'll do
to our texture shader is I'll add
another uniform that's gonna be the
color and that's what we'll use instead
of this right so instead of just hard
coding that value there we're gonna take
in a uniform for it now this is a times
ten little texture scale thing I'll
leave it there for now but obviously you
probably want to remove that and just
have it like this and if you really want
to have a texture scale well maybe you
could add a uniform which is like your
texture scale or something like this
right but for now just because I still
want that tiling effect just for fun
really I'm just gonna keep it there okay
so this is a we have it that's really
old a modification we have to make to
our shader now it actually takes in a
color and the other cool thing that you
could do here is basically what I
described in the last episode as well
which is that if you do want to use a
texture like you have that checkerboard
background but you want to tint it a
particular color then you can also do
that just by multiplying it with you
color and then setting your color to
something other than white if you said
you call it a white it'll just basically
again be 1 which means that
that's relevant to the equation which
means that it's just the texture that
you're gonna see right but if you
obviously don't pause it as one if you
pass it in as like 0.5 in the Alpha
channel for example then you'll get that
texture at half capacity for example
which is something that could
potentially be useful to what you're
doing okay cool so that's that that's
that shader done again I've gotten rid
of the flat color shadow now we always
bind the texture shader and in fact if
we kind of do a begin scene here right
and then draw rolled quads then
technically speaking begins in should
bind our shader and that should be it we
no longer should be binding our shader
at every draw now whether or not this is
even worth discussing is questionable
just because this is of course a very
simple 2d renderer and things are gonna
be very different once we actually build
a proper one
but for now yeah you could just get rid
of that that binds entirely and
obviously we don't have to set up the
projection matrix twice either we just
find the texture shadow because that's
our only shadow now and then we actually
set that UV projection map for and
that's it that's ready to go the next
thing we need to do is basically set
uniforms like float 4 which is the color
and then like transform and basically
stuff like that ok so this becomes part
of the texture showed up so if we submit
a if we submit a chord with a color then
obviously we want to upload that uniform
color right and then what we need to do
is bind our white texture here right so
that's what needs to happen we officer
don't have a white texture yet so we'll
do that in a minute and then the other
thing that's important is over here for
draw cord where we actually draw a
textured cord we still need to set that
you color otherwise it'll be left over
from what it was the last time so in
other words if we draw if we drew a red
square earlier and then now we're trying
or textured a cord then what will happen
is it will tint it red so we don't
really want that probably at this rate
if you just specify a texture no kind of
tinting color which might be something
that you do as I mentioned then you can
just basically set this color to just be
one one one
right or fact I think it's probably a
little bit better if we just try
chilling that for one right so this is
just gonna be pure white no change on
any of the values of our texture okay
cool so that's that again if we try and
run this right now with no texture bound
this is probably going to give us black
to black quads or actually a might they
might all be textured with the
checkerboard texture and I say it's not
too composite of me I guess I changed
the head off actually did I even change
the head up I'm not even sure why it's
turning a full recompiled yeah so you
can see what it's done is it's actually
giving us that checkerboard texture
multiplied by ten with the that's why
it's so kind of high resolution I guess
because it's multiplied outside corners
by ten as well and it's kind of tinted
them so that's exactly what I kind of
described right with the tinting effect
that you couldn't change now obviously
we don't want this to be textured the
reason it's like this is because when we
render we bind this texture right and
then that's it it's just that's the
state of OpenGL the texture is bound
until something else gets bound to that
slot to that texture slot or unbound
right so I don't know if we have an
unbind function but if we do know how we
don't doing okay if we did have an
unbind function which we know and we've
kind of bound slot zero yeah so what of
what I could do just to cheat I guess is
just basically do GL bind texture and
then interview GL texture 2d and now
I'll just bind nothing right so in other
words we're basically clearing that
texture slot nobody was gonna be bound
if I do something like that and let me
just get back to where I was before then
this is kind of like a good little debug
test I guess I know what that is so if I
do that then what we should probably
expect to see is just black basically
yeah and you can see that we're getting
black the reason is that when we're
sampling from a texture that's not
balanced at all all right which is not
something we should be doing so that's
where that kind of white texture comes
in now what we could do is just open
Photoshop real quick and just make
literally a 1x1 pixel texture that's
just filled with a wide and then load it
is a file and do all that clearly that's
completely I'm
Cerie what we should do is just extend
our texture API a little bit just to
make it so that we can basically create
a texture just on the GPU and then set
its data just from card without having
to load any kind of file at all so let's
do that inside our texture header file
here really the other thing I don't want
to add well I want to add two things we
have this texture 2d create function
which is great and it takes an apart
instead what I'm gonna do is create a
texture of a given size now in the
future we definitely want to extend this
with things like format because we might
want to create a texture of a particular
format you know with particular sampling
properties or like mipmapping properties
stuff like that that's you know creating
textures textures in general are just
you know obviously hugely complicated in
what they're kind of used for and
they're kind of I guess scope of
everything they can include and how you
would want to like I guess customize the
texture to set the properties of your
Texas so that's gonna take way too long
for me to just do that now and it's
irrelevant so just keep that in mind in
the future I mean I keep saying this but
I just want you guys to realize that
obviously there's a lot more to this
than what am I seeing
so width and height are what we have
here by the way there is in hazel where
is it in water age because a bunch of
pull requests for accepted here there's
now a conical create scope and create
ref which is quite useful so what this
does is you can say it's just a little
function here that basically just maps
to make shed for in the case of craft so
instead of us typing and make shared we
can just type in create ref which is a
little bit cleaner so that's kind of
cool I guess I kind of like that so
we'll use that from now on instead of
make sure in the credits carps Amole
will do a make unique okay so there we
have width and height of the open gel
texture which is great if we go to open
gel texture we'll add back constructor
and then to wave you know it's 32 high
and then the other thing that we need
that's really important is for us to
actually be able to set the data of the
texture which we can't do right now so
I'll add a function called virtual void
set data void pointer data and then you
32 sighs I'm almost at that equal to
zero so what this function does the
purpose of this function is to basically
for you to be able to give a pointer to
a block of memory and for it to upload
that to the GPU yeah that's really as
simple as it is so in the case of our
texture 2d barbed in jail will override
this of course I will use visual assist
to implement the constructor and and
that function so there we go this
constructor will pull up to the top just
because this is kind of our base node
file constructor and honestly you know
the other thing that we could do by the
way really easily is just have like our
kind of data here and that's no issue
and that's probably the optimal way to
make textures here but I just want to
keep this API a little bit more simple
at this stage and it's just gonna be
more powerful if we can set the data
later because that might be useful for
you know if you need to update your
texture data for example while
everything's well well like after you've
created the texture okay so as for this
I'm really simple will copy basically
starting from about here onwards I think
we'll copy everything up to the image
pre now we have a texture sub image and
all that stuff we don't really need any
of that sort well yeah we don't need
that because we did the texture storage
here that should be enough that should
work so what we'll do is clear it of all
this and again as I mentioned it's you
know will kind of make an RGBA texture
here but in general you probably want to
you know have this parameterised so you
can specify what format you want in the
constructor okay we'll get rid of a set
because clearly that's going to be fine
then I'm gonna be 0 we will set width
and height that's really important like
that antenna format data format is set
that's good and then we basically create
textures we set this up again you know
this stuff is set to repeat for now this
stuff esta is set to linear and nearest
this is also stuff that you want to
parameterize all right but that's kind
of it I think that's done so now what we
want to do is probably go down ok we'll
do
set data this is really easy we're just
through GL texture sub image 2d this is
like I guess a relatively new function
well I mean it's the same one that we're
using here right in fact so I can
probably copy that we can fill it out
ourselves so you know in the past you
have to do like a GL vine texture and
then GL text sub image 2d so you can
still do it that way but you can see
that that basically takes in a target
instead of a a render ID basically so
it's a little bit worse because it's
kind of two lines of code instead of one
and it's two GL calls we don't need that
so level zero X offset Y offset zero so
at the moment this is gonna set the
entire texture right so within high P it
will actually set from width and height
and then the format will be whatever the
format is a recorded as now I don't
really want to hard code that so I'll
set the format to and this is what is
this format actually it's a Joey so
we'll use Jill enum here we'll have
that's gonna be our hmm so how I guess
we'll have internal format and just the
format like that and then we might need
glad to be booted which is fine
of course isn't I can GL had a file so
no issues that and then what I'll do I
guess is instead of well over here I'll
set internal format internal format and
then for my perform at just in case we
end up using this in the future we
definitely don't want to and I guess
doubt a form and I might changes to be
dug format we definitely don't want to
rely on that and then realize that
actually when I was setting it for the
case of floating attention from a file
so we might as well just complete that
and then we'll kind of do the same thing
I guess for here we'll set the internal
format and the data format through the
back now I might as well just get rid of
that I guess I think there's gonna be
any issue with setting a member variable
this is a local variable here okay so
until format and data format has been
set we actually don't need the data
format here which is nice but we'll
still set it up because we'll need it
probably for here for actual Club image
so this is the format's this is now the
data format because we're specifying
data in this case not the kind of
internal representation which is
basically how shaders will sample from
it and then we have the type which is
gonna be always be GL understand bytes
so no issue just hard coding that and
then the data right which will just be
data now you might have noticed if you
were paying attention that size was not
used anywhere that's because instead of
us actually specifying a size for the
buffer or OpenGL wants us to specify
width and height and you can see that
also an x and y offset so we're
basically specifying like a sub region
of course going from 0 to 0 to width and
height is the entire texture so there is
no sub region basically but it does
support that that's why it's written
this way other rendering API is
typically take trade textures as just a
block like a buffer of data so in that
case you do need kind of data and size
and that's it
OpenGL doesn't so this function for us
just kind of will stream in the entire
texture data right so we could just for
safety's sake put a little set here that
says that size right has to equal width
times height times whatever the format
is right so the format right now is RGB
a so basically well I'll set up a little
size thing here so what you'll call is
bytes
I guess per pixel so what this will do
and a channel is actually lower one so
bytes per channel right so what this
will do is if the data format is
actually going to be I do be a for
example then we basically just say that
we're gonna you know it's going to be
four bytes per channel and of course
four bytes per channel is ridiculous so
actually was four bytes per pixel all
the pressure of being on camera here and
then if it's RGB which is the only other
format we support at this point because
we've got RGB an RGB a then it's gonna
be three bytes per pixel right so in
that case we need to multiply this here
so what will happen in this case is
we're basically just asserting that the
size is in fact equal to the size of our
the size and bytes the way of specifying
here it has to be the entire the buffer
has to be the size of the entire texture
because we have to give it a full
textures worth of data if we don't like
we don't currently support doing that so
basically
[Music]
data must be entire texture alright cool
so there we go just little setup there
to make sure that everything is fine and
of course you know you probably don't
want to do this calculation like for
example if we're not asserting but you
know we'll leave it like that for now
okay cool so that's it right that should
give us everything that we need so if we
go back to render A to D what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to basically make a
texture here ref texture texture 2d and
this is going to be just a white texture
right it's gonna be our standard white
texture after the index buffer I'll make
it so I'll stay white texture astata our
white texture equals texture 2d create
one by one is gonna be the size of the
texture and then I'm just gonna
basically set its data so the way that
will set the data is we will make a un
32t cold
TxDOT i guess old white texture data and
then we'll just set it equal to F F F F
F F F F F right so full F's for every
channel there for an RGBA texture and
then I'll give a point two to that data
and then the size of course in this case
is going to be the size of white extra
data or the size of a Ewing's 32 T which
is four bytes so there we go so that
should all work obviously sureness
nothing should happen battle that should
be fine basically what I'm trying to say
yeah really simple one by one texture
and a swipe it's great so now when we
bind our white texture here we directly
you just should be able to bind it and
like that should be it right so the same
way that we bind the texture that we
specified here in this case we're
binding that white texture now let's hit
f5 and see what happens alright and as
you can see we kind of get the I guess
expected result where it's just a white
texture we're multiplying it with the
color so we get those original colors
that we were looking for and then of
course with our actual texture where we
supply a texture we get that particular
texture that we've specified now again
if you wanted to tint this for whatever
reason instead of specifying one here
like we kind of have you can basically
specify well something that's not not
wipe right so for example
- from a three-point Hey which seems to
be like my favorite thing ever and then
I think we can do a bit of lending as
well so maybe like two point five right
so if you do something like that then
you will actually get a tint so now the
tint is kind of stable as well side
instead of being high code in the shader
you can see it's now tinted like blue
basically and it should also be about
half transparency so you can see
everything's coming Zarqa because that
background is dark so that's something
that you can do if you're into that and
you can parameterize them and have like
a particular texture tint or maybe you
can even have a state that you set for
the renderer or whatever attention is
going to be tinted anyway up to you guys
have fun with that but basically what
we've done here I think is pretty cool
we've collapsed our two shaders into a
single shader which is pretty awesome
now we do yeah now we don't do any kind
of shader blinds at all we just begin
saying we do one shader bind and as that
is it now I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please hit the like
button and as mentioned earlier you can
help support a serious bug on a patient
compost ash said shown are yeah let me
know what you think of this this
approach I quite like doing things like
that's a little little kind of
optimizations which are really nice to
do and kind of make both the code and
the actual runtime estate switching
stuff like that a lot simpler which is
kind of what you want with graphics
programming now this is all great but
obviously we have no way to actually see
these changes in terms of the effect
that they have on our performance
because we're not profiling anything at
all we could use visual studios
profiling tools but apart from being a
little bit mmm a little bit like not as
robust as I would like them to be we
obviously want some general runtime
profiling that hazel can actually
provide so that we can do it on every
platform independent of things like
compilers and and like development
environments so basically from that from
the next episode on was probably gonna
do a little mini series on performance
profiling so we're gonna be writing some
kind of I guess a a performance
measuring and metrics system for hazel
and we'll probably end up extending that
to include things like well we
definitely want to save you time but
also probably things like memory so that
should be pretty exciting taking a
little bit of a deeper dive into like I
guess some of the exhilarate stuff that
we want to have
in the engine so that when we do kind of
develop it further we can be really
aware of like hey how slow is this you
know what's going on here you know are
it like is this thread idle this is
gonna be so important when we start
dealing with different threads as well
because being able to like visualize
basically what's going on and actually
see it like on a timeline that's kind of
what we're gonna be working towards so I
think that'll be really cool and I will
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]